this week we've got pager final finale
finale whatever final finale porn ban
and hot grease you know my mom burned
her face with hot grease once her face
is she cooking like what happened she's
making she was making pork chops I knew
it she'll she had like a pan full of
grease mm-hmm and then I threw it in
there wet yeah she's doing in there wet
and all splattered up in the [ __ ]
blue and like her and I remember her
screaming and crying and I was I think I
was like three or four know what was
happening so I was just like looking at
my mom and later on she had a blisters
all over her face and issue and that it
took my dad to come home I'm like this
is still your mom but she just has a
burn marks off and that's when she
became vegetarian yeah no I remember as
a kid I was cooking some bacon when my
mom wasn't home and then like it caught
fire yeah and I didn't know what to do
Oh like I just left it there no no I I
did the thing you're not supposed to do
the water but water it's crazy yeah yeah
yeah it doesn't mean it definitely makes
sense in your head like why would water
make it go nuts
yeah sorry here also we have a real okay
so we just talking about hot grease so
for our first story it depends a final
pager provider
what has announcements end oh my god
even still to this day will end it
services well doctors still use pagers
doctors still use pagers no the 19 is
when they're gonna end it and that's
exactly true so there are about 1500
users that are still subscribed to Tokyo
tell a message Wow which has not made
any pagers in the last 20 years so it's
just old pagers that's still active
yeah and it's that's just nostalgic
that's a good pager you [ __ ] if
you're like Paige oh my god that's so
true oh yeah this is the old school
pager it was up here are they college
Japanese cut the carnage associate being
broke yeah the screens is supposed to be
dubbers but it's like how ridiculous is
that we thought that was so good having
a pager yes I remember it was like the
newer ones were like this size that's me
yeah I still have it in the US or in
Japan no here yeah my last pager my last
pager was that small yeah they had this
maybe one I had one that was clear but
didn't were lucky did it work I just had
they went from pagers to dope ever
though what was that
sidekicks that's all right oh yeah that
was the first time it was like oh you
kid did the test when it was like then
they said what are we doing why are we
having this yeah it was like I don't
know it was around the same time when
they figured out like why don't we have
two-way communication mm-hmm I [ __ ]
hated the walkie-talkie phones at the
nextel next call phone next telephone I
thought they were dope no because it may
just seem like importantly someone's
that Starbucks that they're like what's
the difference between calling someone
versus guy here what the [ __ ] they were
saying who was hard to understand well
the reason why is because it was a
cheaper signal like it was like it
didn't cost is no no I mean like a
walkie-talkie
yeah like using minutes oh yeah using
minutes is one thing like imagine how
stupid that was where we have we only
had like 600 minutes
oh yeah like free like after 7:00 p.m.
do you pee like hey don't call me after
9:00 it was just like a so stupid thing
like like the hi-hat it's funny I could
have jokes about this because it's funny
like like you had a phone not to use it
it was the thing like you had this phone
and people like you can use your phone
or kami buddy
I can't I kind of saved my minutes like
it doesn't make any sense if you were
paying that's true not to use the phone
I was before was like free emergencies
right mostly yeah mostly what I miss
about pagers is back then you would call
the homie and they would always have
like R&B playing in the background and
then they'd voicemail and in the end
they would do like the deepest voice pop
yeah what's even though the feels like
14 years old y'all was so if you're a
honey leave a name also means the homies
voice a little Freudian slip over there
and then you have your favorite like R&B
songs or something these guys that leave
the [ __ ] voicemails and just like hey
what's up my name is Bart the guy on the
power or 92.3 back APO
via was like a really crazy looking
asian dude yeah yeah I didn't know he
was Japanese yeah on a radio girls would
be calling me a kick-ass voice and then
you see a picture of them he looks like
a samurai dude I'm long ass hair I know
in this day and age he wouldn't even be
you can't pass it up yeah so [ __ ]
what do you want to hear cuz he would be
like you'd have to have to be on the
Internet you deputy I have a Twitter
it'd have to be about all aligned back
then it was just the voice if you had
the voice I didn't know but they're
saying I learned from this article that
pagers and that technology was developed
in the 50s and 60s but they already
until the 80s I would know I was
tripping out like I thought it was only
around for like 2016 I thought like the
90s that's just crazy but yeah and then
so now while we've had radios and phones
and you know a long time and they just
figure like how can we send a signal and
get a message about or they've had like
you know it's like you know the
Telegraph for a telegram yeah yeah so
they've been sending signals for a long
time a [ __ ] shoestring homie that
[ __ ] was tight in the world for [ __ ] you
have to have the shoestring tight though
oh is that what it was yeah if it's
looser does
work see I know I refuse balloon string
it works really good sound that doesn't
sound right either I don't believe here
he said it would conviction but I don't
know if it's a real news yarn it's a top
string like really far away oh not far
maybe like maybe he'll they're
advocating yeah like a [ __ ] think I
failed because I had it what it makes
more sense that it's yeah
I think I just have it Matt loose and
like could you hear it like nah I'm like
this [ __ ] hella loops and [ __ ] yeah
yeah it was just [ __ ] loose alright
for our next story so did you guys hear
about how Starbucks is now banning porn
or it's gonna want banning porn oh my
god there's people watching porn at
Starbucks yeah so they've been they've
been allowing porn at Starbucks for this
whole time and so now they are going to
block pornographic content from its free
Wi-Fi starting next year so the funny
thing here is that you porn that adult
web site they are now you know Starbucks
explain you porn you know the adult web
site what made you think it was adult I
don't get it they're now blocking
Starbucks from it's not [ __ ] funny
dude that's like somebody they're
banning service that's like somebody
getting denied from like Berkeley but
they're sending them of religious
rejection letters you know I don't want
to go to your college dude yeah how
about that you know that you know if
they put out a campaign if like all the
porn companies were like putting out of
campaigns being like hey ban Starbucks
you know how fast Starbucks would be
like alright yeah you can watch they'd
probably win like we don't want to
censor you that'd be crazy if they lost
like a billion dollars in money is it
appropriate to be watch hell yeah do you
like oh good
laughs but I don't I don't want to see
other people already walking by late he
thinks it might write a script but
they're looking at like you know that's
pretty [ __ ] bold that's very bold I
mean don't they have table is that kind
of like there's a wall behind you and
there is the point of watching porn if
you're not jacking off some people just
mental masturbation
so you're just drinking a [ __ ] latte
with like a reduced fat turkey bacon
salad yeah tomorrow maybe they can't
jack off at what is the point of that
I'm diagur with you I got I'll get the
point if I even watching porn at
Starbucks yeah that's it
then how about this if you are watching
porn at Starbucks maybe you doing some
investigating or you're like what I'm
saying that you can't just like I don't
I don't get that it should be about
appropriate behavior in public is one
thing I'm in place babe time to place
but for them to be like what we're gonna
dictate what's you know what's what what
we feel is appropriate was it a problem
maybe was an epidemic it'd be one thing
if like yeah there was like this Sunday
it's like that guy that comes in every
nice you know but the fat guy would get
kicked out anyway for being like you
know if I had to think I'm additional
you here it's for all the husband's that
can't watch it at home so they watch it
and then they burn it into their memory
and then go home and jack off on the
spank bank yep what's more of a problem
I think is when every Starbucks bathroom
you open the bathroom is always a
homeless man coming out of it [ __ ]
like grease all over the floor and
they're like taking showers in there
that's more of a nuisance I think or
inconvenience perience I'd rather take
that than watching someone jack off I've
never seen one person watch porn or
jackoff at the Starbucks it's always
somebody that thinks they're a [ __ ]
director or writer well these two
Starbucks even notice the people there
we just make it out this also tells me
that they're like checking what people
are looking at so that's kind of scary
yeah I know [ __ ] I don't even want to
be on the Starbucks Wi-Fi no like
knowing that they're the Dare day they
got somebody going like people looking
at a lot of
maybe they're just doing it visually
looking for like employees I figured
there I think if they're looking on
their server or whatever nanak is see
where things are gold is just have
[ __ ] Wi-Fi like what's it called like
the airport where barely works that's
true there white place really good
because I've gone and I'm ik in my car
still and I'm like worthwhile so it's
like you know what cuz that's good
enough just for you to check your email
is [ __ ] but it's not enough for you to
stream [ __ ] crazy videos because
that's an HD porn out there nowadays I
know there's this group called enough is
enough it's an internet safety group and
so they have been subpar monitor after
the company the coffee company to stops
letting people use a public Wi-Fi to
watch porn because there are a lot of
sex offenders and other like convicted
sex offenders by using oh so it's like
[Laughter]
none of us thought of child porn like
it's like they're gonna download it
there where it's like no one knows yeah
go about like because child porn is
illegal you have to go through some
weird [ __ ] to get that stuff and don't
try to find out whoever's yeah cuz it's
illegal yeah because you have to go
through some black porn you know it's
funny about that those like if you're
like you know if say you're 15 like when
you were 15 if you send a naked picture
to your friend
you're now trafficking up in child
pornography and so you can get in
trouble for them I've heard that this is
on the radio I heard that a parent send
their kid a picture
of themselves when they were younger and
it was like a bathtub thing of him in
his sibling and then somehow that got I
don't know how that got interfere door
whatever but then the dad ended up
having to get imprisoned or whatever yes
yeah for like for a family picture yeah
and then it was like well wait a minute
this my kid like I'm not doing that and
he had to like prove and jump through
all sorts of Hoops oh I'm kind of glad
that it's that strict it's a little
extreme but yeah it's also that what you
were saying how they're watching what
we're sending and what we're doing it's
kind of watching everything I always
thought that like I always thought
snapchat was gonna get in trouble
because there was like a whole thing
about like you know how they blew other
pictures are supposed to disappear yeah
right but then I then there was like
rumors that like no the pictures are all
on a server then I thought if you have
all these pictures on the server then
you have child pornography on your
server oh yeah a lot of underage kids
are just like you know they're sending
each other pictures and you can't have
that and then if he and if they sell
let's say they sell the company then
whoever buys it is buying you know dad
so that's so I don't know they we don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
and stuff really getting erased you know
the last story here this woman she was
arrested the 61 year old woman named
Charlene she was arrested for pouring
hot grease on a woman during an argument
anger issues how does she have time to
warm up the grease and then while they
were fighting while she was cooking her
stuff that's probably hot already it was
a Thanksgiving dinner huh didn't go get
to her he was making grain oh hold on a
second she's got to be like you just
wait out there while this is heating up
[ __ ] you up headlines are like why this
is spreading is not necessarily the
story I mean yeah that's crazy but it's
hurt much shot this is Charlene what the
[ __ ]
wait just a moment I got the grease
poured on why she's like she's
constantly suspicious of somebody well
she's just more afraid she just wants
everybody to look like her she looks
like Sally from Nightmare Before
Christmas I could see that she looks
like she has a Venus flytrap on her eye
she definitely looks like a Tim Burton
character you know that I did notice her
skin looks amazing for being 61 yeah she
looks elegant yeah she doesn't look 60
only women like you know I mean [ __ ]
crazy like this would be like the shoes
match the shirt nice it just looks like
she inspects jewels for a living he's a
diamond ex-inspector yeah yeah this
woman gets into a lot of trouble because
she already had two outstanding warrants
for criminal damaging you know
I will not get in an argument with her
she looks like a she looks crazy answer
what if you're just like oh she's the
greased killer that's are like serial
killer names increase killer degrees
Taylor just cranky but if she's just
crazy for crazy though like you're like
oh thank you I hope you have a nice day
what the [ __ ] well obviously she has
something going on I mean look at her
like you know that this is like that's
you're talking about guns she shouldn't
have guns or grease coming a meme now oh
yeah a lot of people did you see the guy
with a thick ass neck and then the guy
oh yeah they're homies now I don't like
all you tried too hard I mean the fact
that they're in the same video I'm like
that spot well that do his neck is so
awti it looks like he swallowed a coat
hanger [ __ ] were they're like they
like don't make fun of him and then they
throw Nick in there oh yeah yeah that's
a lot to swallow all right Nicholas
a great name that makes sense
hi my name is Nicholas like for example
this is one of the replies that is
[ __ ] up on her Oh what is that a
[ __ ] meerkat or something oh it's
taking forever to load but anyway yes
brutal brutal place yeah really good
pirate though dude she'd be the best
pirate the whole time then putting great
well she would need yeah it wouldn't be
an eyepatch you'd be like ah I skirt
some curtains yeah she doesn't have a
sweater how did that happen it was like
that no she [ __ ] up her eye thing that
that's gotta be a better eye last yeah
the eyelash right no she's worse
eyelashes look crazy
she's always makes me realize how many I
didn't realize how many women like to
have fake eyelashes I didn't know that
that was such a thing
that's a fake eyelash no yeah those are
those are for sure because it's like
bleached at the end look it's yes she
got frosted tips
she's got 90's boy band that's cream my
grandma looked like that I'd [ __ ]
disown her ass dude you wouldn't even go
visit grandma I know yeah you covered
over baby
no absolutely not ridiculous if the
victim has like severe burns on her ha
ha grease is bad and it's a sticks on ya
ass Bart's mom dude that part with pork
chop with some real energy she has scars
uh she had scars for a while but this is
when I was like three or four sits over
30 years old I had a classmate in high
school and when she was a kid she
reached over the the kitchen pot and the
grease fell on half of her body in her
back and everyone called her fried
chicken
I know he comes fried chicken you know I
know the grandma school playground is
the internet and what sucks is she was
actually a really like pretty girl like
she's cute but she's just half of her
body was like [ __ ] to face like it
was like barn to Chris face - no no it
was finally like her face is fine and
everything her neck from here down to
her arm and to their back yeah she
showed you know you could see it yeah
get this just spoon with her but on but
on the good side up oh she's flirting
with you man if she shows you all that
no I mean like I think she was fine when
she got used to it because she would
wear like like tank tops and stuff and
people know she was one of those she's
like whatever
[Music]